[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña una activista afgana por los
derechos de la mujer ella acaba de
llegar a francia huyendo de los
talibanes por razones de seguridad no
vamos a dar su nombre
bienvenida gracias por acompañarnos en
france 24
gracias realmente lo aprecio cuál era su
trabajo antes de salir de afganistán
yo estaba trabajando como coordinadora
de género en save the children antes
estuve trabajando con silvio society
waitz network
son organizaciones para aguas para
luchar por la protección de los derechos
de la mujer y los defensores de los
derechos humanos en afganistán como
salió de afganistán como llegó aquí a
francia
con mi marido postulamos al asilo en
países europeos pero por suerte el
gobierno de francia nos mandó una carta
para decirnos que nos lo habían aprobado
y diciéndonos que fuéramos hacia el
aeropuerto
allí había miles de personas de mujeres
niños
algunos tenían documentación esto
desafortunadamente no fue posible para
todos
el ejército a mano estaba disparando a
la gente lanzando gases los niños
estaban muriendo delante de nuestros
ojos no había agua ni comida ni baños la
gente quería probar suerte y salir del
país pero lamentablemente solo algunos
lo consiguieron y otros incluso murieron
en el intento cuando los de life
cómo se siente actualmente después de lo
que ha pasado en estos últimos tres días
todavía estoy yo
porque perdimos todo solo pudimos tomar
algunas prendas de vestir klotz perdimos
nuestra identidad nuestros documentos y
toda nuestra ropa nuestra casa yo
siempre quise venir a francia pero como
turista no escapando como ahora
ni venir como refugiada
incluso ahora cuando intentó dormir y
descansar
no puedo olvidar esos momentos
esas imágenes de los cuerpos muertos de
los disparos
de los gases usted ha recibido mensajes
de las personas que trabajaban con usted
en afganistán o de otras mujeres
activistas como usted
y que se quedaron en el país que no han
podido salir
muchas de esas mujeres viven en las
provincias
están preocupadas todavía de que se sepa
que están trabajando con ongs
internacionales por los derechos de las
mujeres
[Música]
porque los talibanes no creen que una
mujer es un ser humano
cuáles fueron los progresos en la
situación de la mujer en afganistán
estos últimos 20 años en la comunidad
internacional
los derechos
y otros derechos que residentes de west
tras la cna de cáncer mostrar muchas
mujeres sacrificaron sus vidas pudimos
verlo en las noticias
de huff cadetes nos desunen gandhi
systems woman's recientes como se
imagina usted el futuro de la mujer en
afganistán bajo el dominio de los
talibanes
pienso que no hay futuro para las
mujeres en afganistán porque como dije
antes los talibanes y esta gente nunca
han tratado a las mujeres como ser
humano como una persona individual
eso significa que usted no cree en las
promesas de los talibanes de que ahora
va a ser distinto que hace 20 años
no van a cambiar hoy cuando
aún tienen esa personalidad
quitaron a algunos periodistas sin
cambiar golpearon a algunas mujeres por
su manera de vestir porque no usaban
burka y bando incluso la dijeron los
taxistas que no tomen pasaje las mujeres
que viajan solas sin hogar como debería
organizarse ahora la resistencia en
contra de los talibanes
electoral
necesitamos poner en marcha programas de
apoyo en las redes sociales y hacer
presión sobre los gobiernos las naciones
unidas y otros países para proteger a
esta gente incluso si ellos no tienen la
suerte de salir del país pues no es la
única solución salir del país y dejar
torio
díganles a estas personas porque
nosotros porque nos tenemos que
sacrificar nosotros cada vez
every time muchas gracias por su tiempo
aunque son materiales
necesitamos más apoyos para el éxito en
la extracción de ayudar a la gente de
los inquilinos pero se adapta parlament
alcanza
mucha suerte y ustedes sigan con la
programación habitual de france 24
[Música]